I gotta be honest with you something got
me in a bit of a lather this week in
fact I was virtually foaming with rage
the hashtag me too movement claimed two
new victims common sense and male
dignity the target of this razor-sharp
rage Gillette you know they're the big
shaving firm will make that they were
the big shaving people for reasons known
only to their own virtue signaling cells
they chose to launch a new ad in the US
showing men trying to stop some simple
old roughhousing between boys at a
barbecue reprimanding young men for
finding women attractive and essentially
supporting the notion most men a
sex-crazed harassing law breaking
bullies is that how they see their
customers the hashtag me to campaign has
shown a welcome light on some wholly
unacceptable practices and deserves
continued success however when the
hundreds of thousands of responses on
the firm's YouTube page are running at a
rate of 10 dislikes for everyone like
it's clear this is one campaign that
needs to throw in the towel right now
Michelle I know you're OK to get
involved in this but for those viewers
who have oh thank you for those viewers
who have not seen it here's a shortened
clip of the ad is this the best a man
can get
instead of excuses boys
we need to make change men need to hold
up
[Music]
because the action we take today will be
seen by the men of tomorrow I can almost
imagine when they were creating that ad
and they would have had I don't know
like a group of trendy 20-something year
old guides and skinny jeans and they
would all have watch that and be jumping
up and high-fiving and all the rest of
it and I bet they're all really
surprised by the response that they've
got for this ad I'm obviously not a man
and I actually sometimes find myself
feeling sorry for the men of today
because you because I think to be a man
you must tread on eggshells wondering
what is okay and what is not okay and
when I watch that advert I almost felt
that I was watching some kind of like
Public Health video I didn't realize
until I got to the end that I was
watching a marketing video for a shaving
company and when I think about that and
I think of men its suicide is the
biggest killer of men I think it's under
the age of 45
but working-class boys are falling
behind in educational standards and I
just think if a brand like Gillette
cares about men and what's the develop
men and the narrative around men there
are so many productive positive
campaigns that they could have ran to
help and support men as opposed to
vilifying them all as some you know
walking sex pest in bullying abusive
species and by the way Gillette also
when it comes to women I find it
fascinating how they're focusing on the
men's side of things but yet very
comfortably still charging more for
their pink razors oh that's a called
Venus magic probably more liberal among
the teams how do you respond to so I I
actually posted on social media about
this ad but and tried to be sensible and
course lo and behold I was that I was
gunned down by all sides inside and so
my basic point is that the conversation
around masculinity must be had it's
needed it's necessary and it must and
the notion of masculinity must always
update just like every notion must
update and keep up with the times
however I think it's that ad and the
sorts of men you described in their kind
of skinny whatever skinny items what
they're wearing but the people that
would back that ad are guilty of only
presenting half the store
and the other half of the stories the
following if one we're pushing out
messages like that we're not seriously
addressing our parental alienation that
happens overwhelmingly two fathers have
happen is happening to me
fathers who are alienated from their
children post divorce or indeed
paternity leave
paternity or even if we look at you know
custody presumptions around divorce
divorce settlements also homelessness
the overwhelming majority of people who
are homeless are men and the reason that
happens is dad how do you feel about the
situation you find yourself in now it's
a daily struggle a bit to remain happy
these are problems that are that are
cast into our law and into our judiciary
and into our culture
you can't tell men to start behaving
less like the traditional masculine
roles then they had grown up with if at
the same time if they find themselves
homeless they go to a council and the
council says women take priority you've
got to sleep on the streets which one I
have our cake and eat it too but let's
don't forget this is an advert for razor
blades you know I don't know what
Gillette were thinking of here in terms
of PR and business you know they're
their signal boosting the very very
worst things about men if I was a bloke
I'd never buy anything from them ever
again but but mostly this ad is
predicated on the fact that all men are
bad and that they have to be taught how
to be good and I don't think that's very
good because all men are not bad and I
just I just think it's not Gillette's
job to be teaching people how to be good
men it's not their job to make political
statements and especially I want to take
letters from a company whose main
motivation is profit Greg that's a fair
summation it does depict us and as Carol
says blokes are basically inherently
even as little boys well I was the whole
thing yes and I thought I quite liked it
I thought it was okay but I was if I'd
been Gillette I wouldn't have done it no
I mean I've commercially I don't think
it's gonna be into their advantage as a
film it was a very nice film about a
small number of men
let me ask you this you've run companies
if you look at your YouTube page and
you're running ten to one dislikes
v-lite versus a that's a big fail isn't
it
yeah you'd be sitting you'd be sitting
around saying what are we doing the
other rad ix at the 1989 ad that was
terribly positive about men I thought it
showed them as sporty and decent and
loving parents and let's have a look at
that
[Music]
Gillette gel and the contour plus system
with you breast rate the complete
shaving experience
[Applause]
so I have our director singing that
which is a little bit but what I think
that's a very very positive advert I
don't but what they're saying now is all
of that is wrong but you touched on this
I think this is really important I do
believe there's a war on men and
masculinity
since the me - I really think men are
under enormous pressure in a way they
never have been and I don't think it did
me to have to happen yes it's just
ending violence and harassment against
woman it's a good thing it's a fantastic
thing but it doesn't mean you have to
like my bad I mean there is a scardy
quite an interesting pot where they said
is if we won't go the whole thing's too
long but it said is it more or less
difficult being a man today than in
previous generations and 50% of men said
yes not that I think how would they know
I was going to say that's a weird
question if you have 39 percent of women
said no I mean there's certainly I look
back to my farmer you know light-hearted
way but my dad genuinely believes
Saturday's was man's day you know yeah
well I don't know any bloke should go
home and say that today and live there
are cultural attitudes around what it
means to be a man are changing and my
point was that the legal and judicial
precedents are still there and that does
make it harder because the expectations
are still there without the cultural
permissions and so like let's listen to
let's have a look at what the CEO of the
Samaritans said that leads to that
disproportionate level of suicides the
decline of typically male industry and a
rise in family breakdown mean that all
too many middle-aged men now believe
that they fall short of the gold
standard of masculinity there are
neither the providers nor the protectors
their traditional masculinity requires
this focus and desire to live up to the
masculine constan and contributes to the
devastatingly high level of suicide in
men in midlife and I think if we if we
this is very dangerous the road we're
treading
because we're trying to change attitudes
around what it means and notions around
what it means to be a man without
addressing the laws like what they don't
know what they're getting into I mean I
for one will not be buying Gillette
products I assure you but we need to
hear what you let us say yeah so to give
them their right for pie so um this is
from Gary Combe who's the president the
global grooming at Procter & Gamble and
what he says it's he says it's time
we acknowledge the brands like ours play
a role in influencing culture our new
advert aligns with our slogan and we
believe in the best in men by holding
each other accountable eliminating
excuses for bad behavior and supporting
a new generation working towards their
personal best we can help create
positive change that will matter for
years to come so that's their response I
still maintain my point that I feel that
there's a desperation for brands to jump
almost like social justice warriors I
think that feminism to be politically
and it's it's different but links I saw
a massive advert on the tube the other
day from a bank I won't name them from a
bank basically telling me in the EU
[Laughter]
shaving brand you're a bank stick to
retailing shavers and current accounts
and we'll live in a better world I'm
sure anyway coming I'm saying that
punishment should mean prison
[Music]